Here we have the g function
and I recommend pausing the video
and find out how much g (1),
to find how many g (2), g (3) and g (4) are.
Find each of these four.
Okay, now let's do it together.
g (1), if n = 1,
then we will have this case here,
if n = 1, g is equal to 4.
That was pretty easy.
Now find g (2) if n = 2.
2 is greater than 1 and is a natural number,
so we will use this case.
This is interesting,
because it is determined with respect to the function,
but is not defined with respect to g (n),
but in relation to g (n - 1).
So if n is 2, because here we calculate g (2),
we will have g (2 - 1)
or g (1) plus 3.2.
Okay, how much will it be?
We know that g (1) equals 4.
We just found it.
So we have plus 3.2, that's 7.2.
Okay, let's go on.
g (3), we fall again in this case,
because 3 is greater than 1 and is a natural number.
So this will be g (3 - 1)
or g (2) plus 3.2.
Ok, we know how much g (2) is. It's 7.2.
We just found it. It's 7.2.
7.2 plus 3.2 will be equal to 10.4.
And then g (4) - again we come here.
This is g (3) plus 3.2.
How equal is this?
We have just found that g (3) is 10.4.
10.4 plus 3.2 is 13.6.
What we have here,
is actually quite interesting.
We can look at this function g
and we see that it is defined for all positive integers.
Because it is defined for the positive integers,
we can consider it as a numerical sequence,
seeing what is the order here.
The first article is 4,
the second member is 7.2,
the next article is 10.4,
the next article is 13.6.
It could continue more and more.
What is happening? What's happening in this line?
We start with 4.
And in this case, the function gives us that,
if n = 1.
If n = 1, the function will be 4.
Then for each next member
take the previous one and add 3.2.
So, add 3.2 for the second member, add 3.2 again,
and just keep adding,
not 32, and 3.2 - to get to the next member.
We can define the function as follows:
"We have a row where the first member is 4,
and then add 3.2 to get each successive member. "
But this is another interesting way to define it.
This way of defining the sequence,
in which we assign it as an algebraic function,
which is defined for all positive integers,
where we have a base case.
The basic case gives us the first article
and then we have this second case,
which is defined with respect to the function.
Then we have to go back,
so we can eventually get the base case.
This is called a recursive assignment of a function.
Recurrent feature.
With this example we see
how a recursively assigned function can be used,
to define a number row.
As we stood here,
but we could go the other way.
And if we look for g (6)?
Then you fall into this case and you will say,
"This is g (5) plus 3.2."
We will have the previous article plus 3.2
if we look at it as a line.
Okay, then we'll have to find
how old is the previous member.
g (5) is g (4) plus 3.2. And after this
continue to go back and back and back.
But we have already found how much g (4) is.
It is 13.6.
So that's 16.8.
And then to g (5), which is 16.8
add 3.2 and get 20.
So you can start with g (6) and continue, going back,
until you reach g (1)
and then find out how that is.
You are going back to the base case
and then you can fill in all the empty spaces.
Let's take a few more examples.
This feature is here.
Let's say she sets a line.
Let's think what the first four members will be
from this line and once more
I recommend that you pause the video and find it on your own.
Okay, let's do it together.
h (1) is ... very clearly told us that it is 14.
If n equals 1, h is 14.
How much is h (2)?
Now we fall into this case,
because 2 is greater than 1 and is a natural number,
we will have 28 on h (1).
Well, we know that h (1) is 14,
so we have 28 on 14, which is equal to 2.
Now h (3).
In h (3) we fall back in this case.
This will be 28 divided by h (2).
If we look at this as a line,
divided by the previous member in the row.
So, 28 divided by h (2) ...
We know h (2) is equal to 2.
We found him a while ago.
So we go back to 14, something very interesting.
I think you see where that goes.
h (4) will be 28 divided by h (3),
but h (3) we just found it.
Or divided by 14, which returns us to 2.
If we look at this as a line,
we will say: "The first member is 14,
then we go to 2,
then we go to 14,
then we go to 2. "
One way to look at this line
is like just continuing to alternate 14 and 2.
All odd members of the line are 14,
and all even members of the line are 2.
This is one way to look at it.
The other way to look at it is,
that we start with 14
and each successive member is the previous member, divided into,
i. 28, divided by the previous article.
So here 28/14 = 2.
28/2 = 14
28/14 = 2.
And we go on and on, and on,
and that's exactly what's going on there.
Let's solve one more of these tasks.
As this is interesting,
because we now have two underlying cases.
Let's think about it.
We are looking for how much f (4)
and we fall into this case.
4 is greater than 2 and is a natural number.
We will have f (4) minus 2,
so we will have f (2) + f (4 -1),
i. plus f (3).
So f (4) is the sum
of the previous 2 numbers.
Ok, let's find f (3).
f (3) falls again in this case,
we have f (3 - 2) f (1),
plus f (3 - 1), plus f (2),
i. the sum of the previous two numbers.
Let us find out how much f (2) is.
Now we do not have the sum of the previous two numbers.
We fall into this basic case. Now n equals 2.
It will be equal to minus 4.
And now we will find also how much f (1) is.
We see that when n is equal to 1, f is equal to minus 6.
Here are two basics.
Basic cases are those cases that are not defined
in terms of the function itself.
They are needed,
because otherwise you will always go back and forth.
You will never reach real numbers.
But now we can use these to fill in the values ​​here.
The line begins with a minus 6,
then we go to minus 4 as the second member of the row,
and then the third member is the sum of the previous two.
Minus 6 plus minus 4 is minus 10.
And then the fourth member is the sum of the previous two.
We see this here.
The second article f (2) plus f (3).
Minus 4 plus minus 10 is minus 14.
As we can continue on the same path.
So this is minus 14 here.
The purpose of this video is
it is better to familiarize yourself with the recurring assignment of functions
and how it can be used to assign numerical rows.